The Man Who Personally Executed Over 7000
People in 28 Days
The most prolific executioner of all time
is a man by the name of Vasili Blokhin.
Born to a Russian peasant family in 1895,
as a young man he quickly earned a reputation
for “chernaya rabota”, or “black work”,
while serving in the Tsarist army during World
War I- gaining recognition from Stalin himself
for his covert assassinations, torture, and
executions.
Blokhin quickly rose through the ranks of
Russia’s secret police at the time—the
NKVD—eventually becoming the head of the
Kommandatura department.
The members of the department were approved
by Stalin and took orders directly from him.
Under the guise of other positions, Vasili
Blokhin was officially a commandant of a prison-
the department carried out black work missions
specific to furthering Stalin’s cause.
Blokhin oversaw many mass executions and executed
several high-profile individuals himself,
including Mikhail Tukachevsky, Marshal of
the Soviet Union, and two of the former NKVD
chiefs under whom he had previously served.
But Blokhin’s most infamous deed was performed
at the bloody Katyn Massacre.
In 1939, just over two weeks after Germany
invaded Poland, Soviet forces entered the
eastern side of Poland.
Though they didn’t officially declare war,
they captured over 20,000 Polish officers
and detained them in Soviet prison camps.
On March 5, 1940, Stalin himself ordered the
executions of all Polish officers, who would
then be dumped in mass graves.
Over a twenty-eight day period, Vasili Blokhin
personally performed over 7000 of these Polish
executions at Katyn.
Usually, the executions would take place from
dusk til dawn, with Blokhin preferring to
work at night for these types of tasks.
Blokhin would work nearly uninterrupted each
night, reportedly killing a prisoner about
every two or three minutes, averaging around
300 executions per night.
The executions would go like this: after signing
identification papers, officers were led with
their arms bound into a small room that was
equipped with soundproofed walls, a drain,
a hose, and a door or hatch- it was a room
designed for executions.
Forced to their knees, a member of the Kommandatura
would deliver a single shot to the back of
the prisoners’ heads, killing them instantly.
Their bodies would be dragged through the
second door, the room would be hosed down,
and the next prisoner would be brought in.
Blokhin favoured the 7.65 mm Walther PPK pistol
for these types of executions.
It didn’t have as much of a kickback as
other guns, which meant less pain in his wrist
after performing hundreds of executions every
day.
The pistols also rarely misfired, which meant
the victims could be killed with one shot
nearly every time someone pulled the trigger.
For the Soviet government, the pistols were
favoured because they were the make carried
by German officers.
In the event that the mass graves were discovered,
the bodies would contain bullets from a German-style
pistol and the Soviets could deny responsibility
for the deaths.
On April 27, 1940, Blokhin was rewarded with
the Order of the Red Banner for carrying out
this amazingly bloody organized mass killing.
The Order was traditionally given to military
personnel who displayed “exceptional courage,
self-denial, and valour during combat”.
He was given the order secretly in order to
protect the secret nature of the killings.
In 1941, Stalin found himself in an alliance
with the Polish government after the Germans
invaded Russia.
He released hundreds of thousands of Poles
from prison camps, and was pressed on several
occasions to account for the missing POWs.
Stalin pled ignorance, but in 1943 the truth
began to emerge with the discovery of the
mass graves at Katyn.
The Soviet government denied all responsibility
and blamed the Germans.
It wasn’t until 1990 and Mikhail Gorbachev’s
institution of openness that the truth was
revealed through a series of documents highlighting
the country’s role in the massacre.
Blokhin didn’t live to see his deeds publically
recognized.
Following Stalin’s death in 1953, he was
forced to retire.
During the deStalinization campaign that followed,
Blokhin was stripped of his rank and turned
to alcoholism.
A combination of drink and insanity reportedly
led to his death in 1955, the cause of which
is officially listed as suicide.
The legacy of his heinous acts lives on.
Along with the 7000 prisoners of war Blokhin
personally executed at Katyn, he is reportedly
directly responsible for the deaths of many
thousands of other people in prison camps
during the Second World War, aptly earning
him that title of “Most Prolific Executioner”
according to the Guinness World Records.